maman va garder la petite ce soit ça on
pourra lui aussi forfait passerelle à
18h vient mon coeur fait un cas là bas
et attention c'est très simple
vous avez des pousses de rené gonzalez
nous sommes du ministère de l'intérieur
il a trahi la nation
il a volé un avion il est passé sous le
radar
et atterrit sur une base militaire à
miami avec d'autres du pain on vient de
fonder une organisation qu'on appelle
frère du sauvetage
on doit engager des pilotes de ta
voiture
il est important que vous sachiez la
vérité
les organisations anticastristes de
miami veulent que le monde pour ce que
cuba ait un pays dangereux
le seul et unique moyen d'arrêter ces
gens c'est en infiltrant les
organisations terroristes en floride on
a déjà des hommes sur place un réseau
efficace des espions cubains à miami
et avec ces gens on ne sait pas très
bien où finit la lutte pour un tibet
libre et où commence le trafic de drogue
pourrait bien que votre sécurité
celle de votre ep ou celle de vos filles
celle de tous les bancs de vous-même
grave danger
très ivre a pardonné aujourd'hui
moment de vérité
arrivé
[Musique]